[Music]
what's up mkbhd here
and this is the newest red camera this
little guy right here
it's called the red komodo this is one
of the things i was looking forward to
most at the beginning of this year now
you know 2020 has gone a little bit
sideways and a lot of things didn't go
how we thought they were
but i will say cameras especially in the
last like month
have been insane we got the 8k canon r5
and the r6 came out
the 12k blackmagic camera was revealed
and the sony a7s3 just took the world by
a storm
and by the way almost that entire tesla
model y auto focus video
was shot on a7 s3 so if you want to see
that footage
that's there so now this this
fascinating little
red camera it's the most probably the
most niche i'm sure 99 of people
watching this probably have
no intention of getting a red komodo but
for me
for a lot of video creator friends like
me
this is maybe the most exciting of those
cameras
because its potential is through the
roof so
okay let me just start with this what is
red komodo
it's red's mini cine mini cine camera
it's their mini cine camera the whole
thing is essentially a two pound
four inch by four inch cube it has a 6k
super 35
sensor a canon rf mount it has a small
built-in touchscreen
up at the top it has auto focus and it
shoots to cfast cards
and it'll cost right around six thousand
dollars but the most important fact
is it's not out yet this camera is not
done yet it's basically in beta so
matter of fact
every komodo you've seen out in the wild
has been some custom color
whether it's blue yellow or even the one
they're starting to make more of now the
white stormtrooper one
which i think looks sick or this pretty
sweet looking
matte black everything mkbhd edition red
komodo
thanks red now i still paid for it i
still paid full price for it
but you know thanks red for the the
little logo custom engraving and the map
like everything touch that's nice it's
pretty on brand
good look uh so i think we'll start here
with everything that makes the komodo
just like
other red cameras and then we'll get
into everything that's
different from other red cameras and
potentially better so the areas where
this camera is most similar to other red
cameras
are some of the most important which are
the image
the types of files you're going to be
working with and just the overall look
that you can get out of this camera
it is a smaller sensor and from that
i've noticed the image is a little bit
more noisy but in general
komodo footage will look and feel and
grade and work like
monstro and helium footage in fact
i was gonna wait till the end of the
video to say this but just so you know
this entire video is being shot on
komodo i have
i have two so the komodo is shooting
this the komodo i'm working with
and you can see if you can tell the
difference i don't know if you will i
think by the time it goes through
youtube and hits your screen it'll be a
little harder to tell the difference but
it should still look
pretty good so this whole video is
komodo test footage but yeah on the
upside you're still getting
6k r3d raw files or 4k prores if you
want it you're getting the in my opinion
awesome red color science
you're getting that hefty 15 stops of
dynamic range which is a few more stops
than even the r5 and the a7s of the
world and it puts it much more in the
world of other cinema cameras
you're getting global shutter there is
no in-body image stabilization but
not having rolling shutter again puts it
up with cinema cameras instead of
mirrorless cameras and you also get some
of the other weird little quirks
downsides of red cameras too one of the
big ones is you don't get slow motion at
full frame
anytime you want to change resolution it
crops into the sensor
and you max out 6k full frame at like 40
fps so if you want to shoot
60 or 120 you're gonna be cropped in
that's something all red cameras do but
from that point on
it's very different from other red
cameras and it's much more of a hybrid
feels like between the red cameras that
i'm familiar with
and the mirrorless cameras in that whole
world that you guys probably all know
about
and that's kind of on fire right now
first of all it has the canon rf
mount so the same mount as the eos r and
the eos
r5 that whole family which is really
interesting and i'll get
more back to that in a second it also
has
dual battery slots on the back for
off-the-shelf canon bp series batteries
i've been shooting with these bp 975s
which you could easily go with the
smaller 955s when i get my hands on them
but
just these two batteries by themselves
you can shoot for well over three hours
and since there are two technically
they're hot swappable
so it runs down one battery at a time
and as soon as one of them gets kind of
low i can replace it
and it starts off on the other that part
is sweet
and then it shoots to cfast 2.0 cards
like i mentioned in the beginning so no
proprietary ssds
no mini mags just cfast cards that you
can buy off the shelf
in b h somewhere i still wish there were
dual card slots like there are dual
batteries
but there's only one here and that's
kind of a bummer i really like when we
see dual card slots in the mirrorless
world
so how does that translate to actually
using the camera
well a lot of the biggest fundamental
things translate perfectly just having a
smaller
lighter camera that you can throw in the
corner of a car
or in just smaller spaces or even on a
gimbal
i could never fly a monstro camera on a
ronin-s for example
this you could it's only two pounds so
that's been awesome but the actual
experience
and performance of using this camera for
me so far has been
a really mixed bag and that's because
this camera
is in beta like the software is in beta
and just the whole camera is in beta so
rf lens support is actually still a work
in progress for this lens so right now
if you put an rf lens on the camera
it doesn't communicate any info
electronically yet
and actually included in the box when i
unbox the komodo live you might have
seen on instagram
you will find an rf to ef adapter so you
can adapt
a whole canon ef mount collection to
actually communicate with this camera
through the adapter
the menus are pretty basic and i think
they'll mainly stay this way but they
have room to improve as far as
responsiveness goes
again to feel closer to that mirrorless
world and right now
there is not a lot of officially
supported accessories yet
like these one terabyte cf cards i have
that i'm shooting to every time i boot
the camera
it gives me a warning about how they're
not official media and how i should be
very very careful
and then autofocus autofocus is maybe
maybe the biggest indicator overall the
state of this camera
so red cameras in the past and many
cinema cameras
generally don't have autofocus or any
sort of
autofocus system you would rely on but
with komodo
plan on it but it's in beta and from my
experience that just really means it's a
very rudimentary very
simple seemingly contrast based auto
focus system there's no eye tracking
there's no
subject tracking or anything fancy like
that it's mainly just
tap on the screen and hope it focuses
and so so far it's worked
decently well depending on the lens
you're using so you can touch something
on the screen to focus
and it should shift and sort of rack
focus relatively quickly but depending
on what lens
that can involve a good amount of
hunting or missing focus or non-response
which would of course be
unacceptable in the mirrorless world
from like an r5 and also like i
mentioned doesn't work
at all with rf lenses there's no
electronic communication
so it's all happening through an adapter
so i guess bottom line is it's
it's not as reliable on main
shoots as i would want it to be if i
wanted an autofocus camera
which is kind of a great pun because
we're considering
shooting maybe our next auto focus car
episode video with komodo but again for
those videos we rely on
autofocus so it's kind of a toss up
maybe weigh in in the comments if you
think we should try it but think about
this think about a future
where you can use any canon rf lens any
canon lens
even with an adapter and the native
autofocus just works
and it's amazing the thing about those
incredibly advanced eye tracking and all
those autofocus systems with sony and
canon and everyone else is
they didn't happen overnight those take
a long time to develop
and work on and get better at and red's
never really had to do that so we'll see
how long it takes them and whether or
not they can make a good autofocus
system
but imagine that future and that's
really kind of a big point for this
camera as a whole
imagine a future where there's a whole
ecosystem of competitive third-party
accessories instead of just
the hyper-expensive first-party red
stuff that's been a barrier to entry
for so many people for so long where
i've never really
been able to recommend a red camera for
anyone
despite how much i love them because you
don't just get a red camera you also
have to get the red ssds you have to get
the red monitors you have to get the red
modules
and all that cost adds up over time but
with a camera like this if it's out for
longer and starts to get traction
well then you start to see the wooden
cameras and the small hd's and the cages
and all these things start to be
more popular even the batteries and the
media so for people who do like the look
of a red camera and the image quality
but haven't really been able to get into
the world maybe maybe over raven maybe
komodo maybe
this is that new entry point i feel like
i'm personally a proponent of
better image quality in general people
love saying i focus on the cameras too
much
in like smartphone reviews but i can't
help it i want people to be able to
record and make
the highest quality stuff and the better
cheap cameras get
and the cheaper good cameras get the
happier we can all be and all that is
not even to mention the already pretty
impressive remote app control
with very little latency thanks to the
wi-fi antenna right on the side of this
camera so let me end this by
just answering maybe the most frequently
asked question i've heard from
some of my creator friends which is
should i
buy should i get a red komodo
right now honestly probably no and
that's not just from the stuff like that
i don't like about this camera
it's been a few weeks and these are my
impressions but there are some things i
don't like like i don't like that there
is no hdmi
only sdi for video out i don't like that
the shape of the camera is
a box but it isn't as modular as some of
the other boxes like they could have
made it more ergonomic like the shape of
a mirrorless camera for example since
there are no modules i don't like that
the display is
fixed up at the top it's almost unusable
for a lot of angles that i like to shoot
and something that feels a little more
detached or even swivelly would have
been awesome but it's not any of that
i wouldn't recommend komodo because
people buying a camera right now
who really need a reliable camera with
an autofocus system
or just all of its features right now
that's not what you're getting
so i guess my number one rule about
buying tech
and i've said this before is don't buy a
piece of tech
based on the promise of future software
updates you should buy it based on
the fact that you like what it is right
now i'll talk about that in smartphone
videos
and i think that the ceiling for this
camera the potential
of once there's an ecosystem of
third-party accessories around it
once it has all of its features once the
menus get nice and fast once autofocus
works
and you can use this small little camera
and get red video quality
the ceiling for this camera is so high
that
once it gets anywhere near that ceiling
then i would recommend getting a red
komodo
but there's got to be you know people
like me willing to go out and test it
early
before that point so really that's
pretty much it i just wanted to i know
this isn't a video most people are going
to care a lot about or watch but
i'm excited about these cameras and i
felt like sharing and a lot of you were
asking so
here you go it's red komodo thanks for
watching
and i'll catch you guys in the next one
peace